it's personal thank you I am you are
what you were saying seems to depend on
an idea of border in order between
opportunity to members of the community
and in order between a community and God
I was wondering and it seems like your
idea of focusing on an interpretive
rights it's also to kind of enjoyed it a
community can remain itself even when it
interacts with other communities but in
a situation Russian communities come
together and they have to reorder adil
themselves and some of the rights that
they see is objective different what
happens what what what approach would
Christianity take to the situation what
what in your view what's what's those up
that it seems to me there are no are
there are no quick fixes in the
political realm that is to say in a
sense I can't answer your question
because I don't know what would happen
would entirely depend on the weather one
was a very much minority community
whether they were were more or less
equal you know in their population so
that there had to be a I mean I I
presume you are now talking about a
political situation because there would
be no other reason why they would have
to 22 as it were the right that their
their conceptions of object or goods
would be endangered by by other
communities is that right have I got
that don't know that but but but how did
they live together in a political
societies is that is that is and and so
I I just wanted to that was just a
clarification of what you were getting
at so I would go back to I don't know if
if if if the two communities were
perhaps and about equal in population
they might have to have that the
somewhat separate legal systems that
there might be as for instance some I
think has been the case but is
progressively less so in in in India
accommodating on different communities
at certain levels you know so so if it's
a federal system then then we're
different community laws are affected in
what would depend on the level at which
these problems arise on the there is a
common good the in the political society
if it wants to stay together as a
political society there is a common
political good which is going to
require a rather delicate negotiation of
communal goods when it's a matter of a
small minority I they may be they may
well be protected as much as possible
within public law in terms of the
internal workings of the community but
not have a public representation I'm
speaking out very much as a person from
the British Isles where some religious
institutions do have public
representation and others don't
different political systems handle that
differently but do you see the point in
a sense I'm making in relation to your
question that the there's uh there is no
one way of handling it but I think that
the the what I would call the ideology
of a gala tarian lights in which all
individuals and all communities have to
be treated treated equally to be
respected equally his is is in many
societies not only and not a good idea
and doesn't actually serve the common
good